you're about to deliver a budget in
almost unprecedented circumstances we
could be on the cusp of an economic
global crisis call us by coronavirus
what do you think the economic impact
could be well I think the first thing
say is that obviously I understand
people are anxious about this and you
know the good news is that we're well
prepared and from an economic
perspective in particular you know we
come at this in a very strong position
do you look at our unemployment figures
or a record lows record numbers people
are in work wages have been rising at a
pretty rapid pace for the last couple of
years so you know we start in a good
place and that's important because that
means that we can take whatever steps
are necessary now the range of scenarios
that might happen but what people should
know is I'm working hard with the team
to make sure that we have the
interventions required to help anyone
through a difficult period first and
foremost support in public services but
also helping vulnerable people and
indeed businesses to get through
anything they might be coming our way
I'm keen to sort of unpack some of those
potential interventions you're talking
about public services are you ready to
give more money to the NHS absolutely I
mean we will we stand ready to give the
NHS whatever it needs so there could be
like an emergency funding package for
the NHS if necessary I mean we've
already deployed funds to the NHS both
for vaccine development and immediate
response so that's already happened as
you would expect and I think it's you
know it's important to remember that
we're able to do that because of the
fact that we're in a strong position
today right it's because of responsible
management of public finances over the
past several years that I can sit here
and tell you yes I can take whatever
steps are necessary to help us get
through this you know because of those
decisions that we made in the past and I
think that's just a helpful reminder
about the importance of responsible
economic management but I say that we
you know the economy is in a good place
and we will get through this and on
business something else that you
mentioned I mean it's gonna be a really
difficult time for business we've seen
the stock market's falling fly Bea's
collapsed some people are saying that
worst case nor is 105 others could be
off work sick are you prepared to
intervene to help businesses that might
be struggling well I'll talk a little
bit more about it on Wednesday obviously
but you know you're right this could be
a challenging period for businesses so
you know as you said if 20 percent of
your workforce and unable to come to
work
you can't do what you normally do that
it's gonna have an impact but it will
impact for a temporary period of time I
think that's the key thing so it's like
I take more responsibility series to
make sure what do we need to do to ease
the burden on business over that
temporary period of time to make sure
that they have access to the cash flow
that they need to bridge through a
difficult period so that they can emerge
on the other side strong and ready to
get back to normal so you can
effectively bail out business it's a bit
like in the financial crisis yeah I
wouldn't necessary you know I think
bailouts not as very the right word but
there are there are policy levers we can
take to ease the the short-term burden
on businesses cash flow you know these
are businesses that we think are viable
sustainable that you know have a bright
future but they're going to have a
temporary period of disruption and
that's where our interventions should be
focused and businesses will spend months
dealing with the coronavirus and they
may then be faced with a situation where
they will then be faced with a situation
where they have months to then adjust to
what would be the biggest change in
their trading relationships for a
generation at a time when they're
already struggling potentially after
coronavirus can you see a situation
where you may extend the brexit
transition period to help businesses
know I think very clearly the Prime
Minister has been clear that we we don't
want to extend the transition period I
think people are fed up of you know
having more delays and people not doing
what they say in this regard and again
the good news is that we've got off to a
good start the negotiations have started
in earnest our team have been very well
prepared for a while and a lot of the
work that we did last year preparing for
leaving the European Union it is very
helpful and valuable in this regard and
that and we've already started that work
this year to make sure everyone's ready
for those new trading relationship at
the same time the situation has changed
potentially because of coronavirus it's
can be a really tough time for
businesses as you've outlined they'd be
on the frontline of dealing with what
could become a pandemic and we've Boris
Johnson famously once said eff business
is that what you're preparing to do by
not contemplating extending the
transition I think first and foremost I
passionately believe as does the
government in general about the
importance of a dynamic free enterprise
business economy in this country you
know first foremost because it that's
what's going to drive growth that's
what's going to raise living standards
that's what creates jobs for people
and ultimately pays the taxes that then
fund all our public services so I
passionately believe in making sure that
we support business but you know when it
comes to new trading relationships that
work has been going on for quite a while
we've been very clear and transparent
with business about those and we are
actively helping them to manage that
transition you know over then we've got
the good news is we've got you know a
long time before we get to that point
okay and let's move on to the budget
something that I know you've been
focusing on over the last few weeks and
you're announcing some new money to
tackle flooding just explain what's the
plan well we've said previously that you
know we are ambitious when it comes to
investing in this country's
infrastructure and flooding is a part of
that you know what we're announcing
today is a doubling in cash terms of the
amount of money that we spend on flood
defences in this country it will go up
to just over five billion pounds that's
doesn't double the amount of the current
program it's gonna pay for around 2000
different flood schemes around the
country it's going to protect over three
hundred thousand homes you know we've
all either in our constituencies as MPs
or watching on TV seen the devastation
wreaked on communities by flooding
you know this will make an enormous
difference to people's lives and I think
it's absolutely the right thing to do
and this is something that wherever you
live whether in the Southworth or the
Northeast this impacts you this
investment will make a difference some
of these people though you've seen their
homes flooded have suffered multiple
times they've heard the promises from
governments before why should they trust
that there should be any different well
in general I'm very keen to make sure
that we deliver on our promises Trust is
important we set a lot of things in the
election campaign err in our manifesto
and what you'll see next week in the
budget in general is a government that
believes in delivering its promise is
doing what it says this was part of it
we said we would increase investment in
flood defences we're going to deliver
that that's what I'm announcing today
but you're right about places that have
been flooded repeatedly so in addition
to the announcement on more flood
defences I'm also announcing today an
extra 200 million pounds to fund flood
resilience in particular communities
across the country that seem to suffer
from repeated flooding and that's
something that local areas have asked
for so they'll be able to get support
for them as a local community to help
build their own resilience plans whether
it's urban drainage whether it's better
coordination between local authorities
and I think that money will be again
very welcomed by communities where as
you said this seems to be happening on a
regular basis you talked about the
manifesto and some of the promises in
the election in a big part of that was
kind of leveling off so moving resources
away from London is that something that
you're looking at in the budget I mean
could you couldn't move the Treasury to
the north yeah absolutely you know we
believe in making sure that wherever you
live in this country there's opportunity
for you you know that's what leveling up
means in practice is not just about
building a road here or a railway
station there it's about ensuring that
everyone can fulfill their dreams right
and so that's pretty you know I want to
make sure the Treasury's at the front
foot of that we are you know driving
economic policy in this country it's
important that we have a presence
everywhere in this country so we will
have a new economic campus in the north
you know led by the Treasury we're about
a fifth of our headcount over time we'll
move will be joined by members from
other economic facing departments and we
will also be opening offices in Northern
Ireland and Wales to complement the one
that we have in Scotland as well you
know I think that's absolutely the right
thing to do and it will be you know it's
a sign of our intent on this delivering
on this agenda okay now you took over
from such a jabot as Chancellor just
three weeks ago and one of the things
that you inherited from him are the
fiscal rules these come self-imposed
limits on how much a government can
borrow or you can keep them well first
of all I believe strongly in the
importance of sound and responsible
management of public finances right and
as we just talked about it's important
that we have that so that we can respond
to things like coronavirus if you look
at our track record over the past
several years we managed to bring a
borrowing figure that was 150 billion
pounds of GDP to the lowest level in 20
years quite straight quite yet obviously
you know you'll hear from the me from
the budget next week but what I would
say is you know I strongly believe in
the importance of sound fiscal
management responsible management of the
public finances you will always get that
from a Conservative government and that
you know after you'll hear more on
Wednesday at the same time we're trying
to work out you know who you are what
kind of chance are you going to be where
your instincts are I mean it sounds to
me like you're minded to keep the fiscal
rules I said you know we've got a budget
on Wednesday so you know we'll be able
to talk about it after that but I think
the importance of a responsible economic
managed
is key to me personally you know but we
also we do want to do everyone all the
promises that we made to people and and
I said we want to level up across the
country we want to invest in public
services we want to unleash the
potential of our businesses you know
we've got an exciting agenda and we will
deliver on all of those so if you do
want to have any sound economic
management something you've been talking
about a lot during the interview you're
going to have to choose aren't you
between balancing the books through
raising taxes or cutting spending so
where are your instincts you someone who
is like a big spender or you like a low
tax kind of guy what was your instincts
my instincts are to deliver on the
things that we said right I believe in
repaying people's trust I think over the
last few years people have been let down
by people not doing what they instincts
my instincts on that so you asked about
tax right we we said actually in the in
the campaign we believe in those on
lower income should pay less tax so you
know you might rightly expect me to
focus on that we've talked about
national insurance thresholds we've
talked about raising the national living
wage to you know this year starting one
of the largest cash increases in its
history you know so those are my
priorities helping those on the
lowest-paid keep more of their money
through lower taxes keep the cost of
living down and whilst at the same time
yes investing in public services that
people rely on and investing in
infrastructure so that opportunity is
spread across the country
you know that's that's what I want to
deliver as Chancellor for this country
that's the government's agenda I mean
one way you could raise quite a lot of
money is through fuel duty which has
been frozen since 2010 is that something
that you're looking at raising again
we're not gonna go through every measure
with you before you know before every
budget there's speculation about any any
number of things but I said my job is to
balance the books but deliver on the
agenda that we said it's about
protecting people's economic security in
the short term delivering on the
promises we made and and laying that
foundation for future growth not that's
how to think about it last week how we
had a slightly extrordinary situation
where such a Javid laid out the budget
that he would have given if he'd been
Chancellor low taxes was at the heart of
it he wanted to cut income tax we wanted
to cut stamp duty what did you make of
those proposals who think they're a good
idea well you know that is you know is a
good friend of mine he's a mentor of
mine and he was my first boss actually
when I was
I got my first ministerial job and it
was a real pleasure to work with him in
the Treasury obviously there's
speculation always about what might or
might not be in a budget well you think
about it he was Chancellor's laid out
his budget and he'd say that much you
know my my priority is tell obviously as
you've said you know I want to have
sound economic management but I also
want to deliver on our promises though
that's what's guiding me as I come to my
first budget it's providing that
Economic Security for people delivering
on the promises that we made and laying
that foundation for future growth and
prosperity
you know that's my guiding principle for
the budget we talked about such a job ad
of course you've course got the job
after he quit in the reshuffle now he
said that he quit because the conditions
that were attached to staying was a
requirement that I replace all of my
political advisers I do not believe any
self-respecting Minister would accept
those conditions you accepted those
conditions so a u.s. self-respecting
Minister was sad and I very different
places because I he had an existing team
of people which I did it so that LC was
a different question for him to come
from but my approach to it is one where
I absolutely think close working between
the prime minister's office and the
chancellor's office is a good thing
close working so you have to stack all
the advisors though you know he's
indifference but here that he had an
existing set of advisors like I come to
it fresh so for me to be able to build
my own team which is what I'm doing but
have that team work closely with the
prime minister's team it's absolutely a
good thing I mean you know it's slightly
odd that anyone thinks that's a strange
thing you know we have an ambitious
agenda that we want to deliver for this
country about leveling up opportunity
everywhere unleashing the potential of
our businesses of our people it's much
we're much more able to deliver that if
we have a close working relationship
between the chancellor's office and the
prime minister's office that's what we
have and I think I said that's a very
good thing did you hesitate at all
before exactly no it's an enormous
privilege to have the job and I now feel
you know great responsibility to liver
on these things yeah you know I took
part in election campaign had the
opportunity to make our case to the
British people about we wanted what we
wanted to do and are now in the very
fortunate position of being able to
deliver on those things
this first budget will start that work
and then we can
or to a parliament where we are able to
really say that yes you know we did
level up opportunity across this country
wherever you live whether you're in the
southwest in the rural area where they
are in a town in the Northeast you know
you feel that your future is better and
brighter as a result of the decisions
that I and the government have made and
that's a fantastic opportunity you
described and Sajid Javid as a mentor so
has he given you any advice and staking
the job
yes Asians have been in touch so yeah
he's yeah he has always given me what
super boss is giving you in more on the
personal side than the on the policy
like what's up yeah try and find some
time for my family which I must say over
the past few weeks is I have not managed
to deliver on but hopefully soon now
it's difficult ii sponsors where you
came into the job and your reputation it
does feel is at stake here your
political opponents will claim that
you're somebody who is effectively under
the thumb of number 10 that this is a
budget look that will have dominick
coming since then fingerprints all over
it i mean what's your response to that
yeah this is the government's budget we
have an agenda to deliver we talked
about leveling up opportunity across
this country this budget will deliver on
those promises we talked about laying a
foundation for growth and prosperity
this budget will deliver on those
promises we talked about investing and
public services this budget will deliver
on those promises so I feel very
confident that people will be able to
judge this budget on its merits and it's
a budget it will be good for this
country
how have you found it personally I mean
I'm quite interested to know how you
found it because there's been a lot of
scrutiny on a budget as any of
Chancellor delivering delivering their
first budget would find but there's been
a particular pressure on you has it been
irritating or upsetting difficult no
it's been tiring I mean we you know
we're working hard you know we've got a
lot to do in a short space of time that
together with the team and I've been I
must say you know incredibly fortunate
to be supported by a fantastic
Department who have risen admirably to
the challenge of supporting me to
deliver this budget to deliver the prime
minister's agenda for the country that's
what we're doing you know is it a lot of
work of course it's a lot of work and
that's a strain but it's also an
enormous opportunity it's the first
budget of a new government in a new
Parliament the first budget outside the
European Union and almost half a century
you know we stand on the cusp of
something really quite exciting here are
their short-term challenges
with coronavirus yes there are are we
daunted by them absolutely not
we're gonna rise to them we'll get
through them and then we can look
forward to a bright future we're just at
the beginning of that and that's what's
keeping us all go it's fantastic okay
and while I've got you on keen to ask
about another story and that is quite
big of a minute of course in Westminster
Priti Patel the Home Secretary facing
bullying allegations which she denies
from three separate government
departments where she's worked is it a
good look for the Prime Minister to be
standing by somebody who is facing
accusations from multiple people that
she's been bullying I think first of all
I personally have a very good
relationship with pretty and enjoyed
working with her and I think she's doing
a fantastic job as Home Secretary right
she's got a very important job
delivering on the things that we said
you know to be keeping us all safe right
with more 20 you know 20,000 more police
officers get him making sure the
terrorists serve their proper sentences
putting in a new borders and immigration
policy those are important things that
she's delivering well but we take any
allegations like this seriously as you
would expect us to that's why the Prime
Minister's asked the Cabinet Office to
have a look at this matter and establish
the facts and it's absolutely right that
that happens and we should let that
inquiry take its course but why should
the fact that she's delivering on the
government's agenda that she's doing a
good job at work why should that have
any bearing on the building of stations
I say we take the allegation seriously
and that's why the Cabinet Office are
looking at them in establishing the
facts of the case okay and just finally
and we're here number 11 you've been
here the boss here for a couple of weeks
now as you were saying in quite a tiring
time and quite an extraordinary at time
have you been keeping going you've been
fuelled by lot some late-night Nando's
late-night Nando's yes yes and skittles
and lots of other things but yeah no
it's a fantastic team right how hot do
you take your Nunda source how do I get
medium hot okay medium hot but I get the
extra hot sauce for the for their chips
on the side but actually I've made sure
other team are getting more broccoli
which no one was really that excited
about other than me and my wife at home
that I was still eating some greens on
the late night late night sessions but
you know I said we're excited about what
we have to do it's you know it's a
fantastic opportunity ahead of us and I
you know I'm confident that you know we
as the government where the country will
rise to this challenge we'll get through
it
and all the exciting plans that we're
going to start laying the foundations
for in this budget are going to pay
enormous dividends over the next few
years and as I said wherever you live in
this country you know our goal is to
make sure that you feel that your dreams
will be realized your aspirations are
ones that we as a government will
support your life is going to be better
as a result of the actions that we take
and Wednesday's budget will be the first
step on that journey okay thank you very
much being on the program thank you